young man from las vegas is scheduled to  be on jeopardy tonight turns out  he was also captain of his high school  varsity quiz team on vegas pbs back in  2014.  it's varsity quiz we also have the  captain of liberty  he's a senior braden smith hey braden  hey um  i know a lot of people probably know  this but briefly describe what boys  state  is uh well it's this sort of government  thing that goes on every year  that guy in the glasses in the bowtie  looks familiar too brayden smith he was  the winner  of that year's varsity quiz the harvey  dondero scholarship that helped paid for  his college education  he graduated in may from unlv he has an  economics degree  now looks to go to law school but first  how will he do in jeopardy well you can  watch mr smith  on this evening's jeopardy seven o'clock  right here on the mighty and powerful  channel eight from one game show to  another  good luck mr smith